The most meaningful art is able to be enjoyed and understood...
...at every stage in life.
With "Calvin and Hobbes", you're always discovering something new.
Read them when you're six...
...and fall in love with the colorful adventures of a boy and his tiger.
But revisit them when you're 16 or 26...
...and they take on an entirely different but equally impactful meaning.
"Calvin and Hobbes" launched November 1985,...
...written, drawn, colored and lettered by this man, Bill Watterson.
Watterson was only 27 years old...
...when "Calvin and Hobbes" was picked up for syndication.
And he had gone through several rejected projects...
...before finally landing on the one strip...
...that would reshape the way people looked at newspaper comics.